bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france expliquez nous quelle est la
situation dans votre établissement
pour le moment les hôpitaux restent sous
tension mais je vous rappelle que nous
sommes sous tension avec des patients
qui restent encore présents hospitalisé
depuis la deuxième et la troisième vague
des patients en réanimation qui peuvent
avoir des semaines en réanimation
nous voyons que les courbes commencent à
se croiser et que on commence à voir que
la diminution du nombre de sorties et
qu'il y a de plus en plus dans quatre
ans et que le nombre commence à devenir
positif il y à plus de patients présents
je vous rappelle peut toujours les mois
de juillet août
cette année là encore plus parce qu'il
fallait donner des vacances à nos
personnels que ce soit en médecine en
gériatrie ont maladies infectieuses en
réanimation aux urgences dans tout
l'hôpital dans les laboratoires ont
radio tous les services nous fermons
nous réduisons un peu notre capacité
d'accueil
donc nous nous trouvons dans une
situation extrêmement difficile aussi
l'épidémie réellement connaissez une
augmentation du nombre de cas nous
serions dans une situation très critique
où il faudrait probablement supprimer
les vacances ou d'un certain nombre de
notre personnel ça ce serait vraiment
liberticide
je dis ça à toutes les personnes qui
disent que la loi qui vient d'être
approuvée et liberticide supprimer des
vacances d'un personnel qui a donné de
son sont ses sueurs et de ses larmes
pour être présente auprès des poètes
présents près des patients ça ce serait
liberticide
quel profil des patients que vip qui
entrent aujourd'hui à l'hôpital
c'est exactement comme cela a été
rapporté dans d'autres pays avec
l'épidémie delta en indonésie en inde au
vietnam dans les pays d'asie du sud
ce sont des patients de plus en plus
jeunes avec des formes graves
la moyenne d'âge en réanimation a
nettement diminué c'est en partie
probablement lié à la vaccination des
personnes âgées à très haut risque mais
nous voyons quand même que cette
nouvelle
touche touche davantage de personnes
jeunes très jeunes et même alors la
vaccination protège nous le savons mais
ce n'est pas 100%
il ya un certain nombre de patients qui
peuvent avoir des formes avec des
symptômes importants
ça protège beaucoup plus des formes qui
nécessite de la réanimation mais par
exemple un de mes patients vaccinés a
été l'ennemi et marty la semaine
dernière complètement confus avec de la
fièvre une semaine après il a toujours
des haltes rage trail j'ai des douleurs
dans les articulations très invalidante
il est très gênée pour s'émouvoir
il ya une sensation de difficultés à
respirer
alors il objectivement il n'a pas de
manque d'oxygène donc il n'est pas
hospitalisé mais il est vraiment très
secoué alors qu'il avait eu ces deux
doses il y a plusieurs mois il n'a pas
été en réanimation
la vaccination la protéger d'aller au
real mais il a quand même fait une forme
symptomatique avec des symptômes loup et
risque de faire un syndrome posco vide
donc non ce virus n'est pas anodin il
faut pas penser que parce qu'on est
jeune et vacciné ça suffit il faut
vacciner et il faut continuer à
respecter de façon rigoureuse et stricte
les règles de distanciation social porté
le masque garder la distance ne pas se
faire la bise être extrêmement prudent
est encore plus prudent avec les
personnes âgées et les personnes à
risque c'est-à-dire toute personne
aujourd'hui qui a un peu de surpoids une
hypertension et diabète 1 problèmes
chroniques de santé doit être
extrêmement vigilantes extrêmement
rigoureuse
est ce que vous constatez quelques
spécificités de cette nouvelle vague en
comparaison aux précédentes dans quelle
mesure le variant delta est plus
dangereux le variant de delta est plus
dangereux parce que il se transmet
beaucoup mais beaucoup plus que les
virus historique
laissons historique deuxièmement il est
plus dangereux parce qu'il touche des
personnes
et comme ils touchent des personnes
jeunes nous avons tendance à penser bien
c'est pas très grave il va rien leur
arriver
mais si il aura rives des choses et nous
risquons d'avoir de façon un peu plus
décalé qu'avec les deux premières
souches auxquels nous avons été
confrontés un décalage des formes qui
termineront réanimation mais je suis
convaincu et se saurait être naïf
puisque nous avons appris déjà avec les
trois wagons antérieures que c'est une
question de temps et que nous allons
voir les hôpitaux en difficulté et les
services de réanimation en difficulté
dans les semaines qui viennent avec une
augmentation du nombre de cas nous
devons être beaucoup plus prudent et le
langage on doit être en permanence de
rappeler à tous nos concitoyens qu'il
faut porter le masque qu'il faut être
raisonnable qu'il faut pas faire la bise
qu'il faut continuer à garder les
distances et qu' il n'y a pas d' excuses
il faut le faire dans notre propre
intérêt et dans l'intérêt de tous les
gens que nous aimons tous les gens qui
nous sont proches tous nos concitoyens
merci beaucoup pour votre regard
enrique casalino chef des urgences de
l'hôpital bichat à paris